should reflect the values underlying the
the commission and iran doesn't i'll
drop it there um on india yes
uh the in addition to this aid you guys
put out this new trouble noticed
a travel alert today uh which mentioned
the authorized departure for families
uh of u.s government personnel at the
embassy and the
was it for consulates um i'm just
curious
is this is this by popular demand or
were there people and i know you don't
want to get any numbers or anything but
we're people wanting to leave and have
people left already
as um under this the
authorized part well thanks for that
question and i think it's important to
um speak for just a moment about what
this was and and importantly what this
was not um out of an abundance of
caution
uh the department of state authorized
the voluntary departure
uh so-called authorized departure of
family members
of embassy at the u.s embassy in new
delhi
and the consulates throughout the
country authorized departure doesn't
force anyone to leave it doesn't require
anyone to leave it gives these family
members
the option to depart if they wish
departure again
is not required uh there's also been i
think some
misreporting perhaps a misperception
that we provided
um revised guidance to private american
citizens in india that is not true
there was a pro forma
reissuance of the travel advisory uh the
level four travel advisory that had
previously
been in effect uh given covid not only
in india um but also
uh globally as as well are people taking
advantage of it
were people wanting this what or or was
it just
decided from here and from the
ambassador or whoever the charge
is that this would be a good idea is
there a rush to the exits
i i don't have uh the numbers i'm not
sure we'd be able to provide them uh
regardless
i just want to know what people are
taking well i think it speaks to the
fact that
we put uh the safety and health uh of
our
um employees and and their families uh
in this case we prioritize that and so
that is why the department thought it
prudent to give them the option
to depart the country if they so wished
so wondering how that's connected to the
outbreak that's been recorded from
inside the u.s embassy or among uh u.s
embassy staff do you have any update on
you know how many people have been
infected among staff there and and how
many fatalities they are there are and
what the embassy and the government has
been able to do to
protect uh staff at the mission well we
addressed this the other day and and to
matt's point uh
numbers are uh difficult um for us uh to
offer publicly given
privacy concerns uh what we will say um
is
that of course our hearts go out to the
people of india as they
navigate the surge it is fair to say
that kovid
uh had has touched every just about
every element of indian society
uh and of course we do have a large
diplomatic presence in india as you
might expect
given our global comprehensive
partnership with india
so while i can't offer any specifics on
usmbc employees or family members or
locally employed staff
uh clearly this is a um pandemic this is
an outbreak a surge of cases in india
uh that has left uh no part of the
country untouched that
outbreak happened sort of despite uh
vaccine you obviously been sending
vaccines out to different
embassies you know was there was there a
delay getting them to the embassies in
india
that perhaps has led to this so as we
mentioned i believe as of mid-april
um uh our missions around the world uh
all of them had had access
uh to the vaccine it was a an effort
that was conducted as
expeditiously as possible um uh
the vaccines have been in india for to
available to our employees to embassy
staffers in india
for several uh weeks now
but obviously with any global
distribution effort it's a complex
undertaking
but it's something we did as quickly as
we could and it's something we're proud
of as we mentioned the other day
not a single vaccine dose was lost
in that massive undertaking nearly 200
000 doses
worldwide including uh to our mission in
india
one thing that's happened in india is um
the the number of critics of the booty
government's performance essay
uh opposition politicians uh by request
of the indian government their their
posts have been removed at least
internally in india from uh
from twitter and other social media
outlets uh does this give any pause to
the united states do you think that's
within the rights of the indian
governments do you have anything to say
well we've made the point um both when
it comes to india and to countries
around the world that freedom of
expression
um freedom of information is a hallmark
of any democracy uh of course
um india is a a large democracy with
whom uh we share
uh foundational uh values uh and freedom
of information freedom of expression
is something we support around the world
yes
uh sure we'll go to lalit and then kylie
when the tool of freedom of expression
is or social media is used as a tool
to incite violence uh against the
government or the
disturbed law and order how how did the
government handle that
how does the how does the government
handle i'm sorry yeah when that
tool is used as a social media user to
incite violence
right that what some some section of the
society has been doing there right
of of course and of course um uh hate
speech
incitement to violence uh is something
that we oppose uh everywhere
um uh but uh uh clearly we support
freedom of expression
um uh while still uh calling out uh
and condemning uh when we see
incitements violence and hate speech
thank you for the all the aid that you
have been providing to india but
i would like to ask you about what is
the use assessment of the
situation of pandemic in india right now
how serious it is is the worst
outbreak of kobe 19 pandemic anywhere in
the world
well i would be hesitant to offer a
sweeping judgment like that i think you
can look at any number of metrics and of
course if you look uh at the case count
the daily case count um of course you
see
a case count that is very concerning uh
and you see
an epidemic that uh just about by any
metric uh is incredibly concerning
uh and that is why uh the u.s government
uh has um
uh uh been engaged deeply engaged uh in
supporting the indian government as i
mentioned the other day
uh even since uh the start of this
outbreak prior to
the recent assistance uh that we just
announced uh the united states had
delivered some 19 million in support to
india's public health system of course
we have spoken to a great deal more
in recent days not only from the us
government from the state department
from usaid from cdc
uh but also uh we have undertaken an
effort to galvanize uh
the private sector uh secretary blinken
as you know took part in a call uh
earlier this week and actually
uh led the call earlier this week with
the chamber of commerce commerce
uh gail smith took part in that call she
took part in a subsequent call
uh with the chamber of commerce uh to
make the point that uh
if we are um to make progress
against this current surge of cases in
india
it can't be something that the indian
government tackles alone it can't be
something that the united states
government tackles alone
everyone has a has a role to play
including the private sector including
the advocacy community
community including uh civil society uh
and that's what we're seeking uh to do
we're seeking
uh to um uh our assistance we hope
uh will have a catalytic effect um on
society
uh more broadly here uh and around the
world to come to the aid
of the indian people between the u.s
government and the indian government
about how the aid has to be distributed
i've heard somewhere that u.s wants to
dispute these aids through ngos and send
directly to the local
government indian government wants it
through rooted through the
federal government itself our goal uh is
to see to it uh that this age
that and this is a goal of course that
we share with the union government uh is
to see
to it that this aid is put to
immediate and effective use for the
details of that i would i would refer
you to
those that are implementing this on the
ground how do you describe the
india isolations in first hundred days
of this administration
well uh of course there's been a
concerted focus on india uh
over the past 100 days president biden
of course did make mention of india uh
in his address last night and i think
you can
uh look at uh that deep um partnership
and commitment to partnership
uh through any number of lenses uh as
you know uh president biden himself had
an opportunity to speak
to prime minister modi uh in in recent
days
uh secretary blinken has engaged uh with
his uh foreign minister counterpart
jaishankar
several times as well there have been
several
high-level delegations secretary kerry
was in india not all that long ago to
discuss
climate secretary austin the secretary
of defense was in india not all that
long ago to discuss elements of our
security cooperation we have engaged
with india in the multilateral context
as well through the quad both at the
ministerial level
and for the first time ever uh at the
leader level
i i've mentioned our climate cooperation
but also our health cooperation
uh and this was something that predates
the pandemic but it is something that
uh intensified uh with the onset of the
pandemic and intensified even further
uh with the uptick in cases uh the very
concerning
uh uptick in cases that we've seen in
india uh in recent days so i think it is
engagement
that reflects our global comprehensive
partnership
thank you thank you uh kylie um addition
to what it said about
u.s diplomats there it also said to u.s
citizens in india
who wish to depart that they should take
advantage of available
commercial transportation options um and
warned
you know against other americans
traveling there so is the administration
considering stopping all flights from
india to the u.s in coming days or weeks
uh so the travel advisory um and and you
know this i think we discussed this
uh in a in a recent briefing um but as
you know the state department uh
recently adopted uh
the uh cdc framework um when it comes to
our travel advisories and so that's why
um uh many countries i believe 80 of
countries around the world
are now at level four travel advisories
uh it is
um a consequence of the state department
um
adopting that uniform approach that the
cdc uses
uh so when it comes to uh our guidance
to americans in india
that did not change uh uh what did
change
was the ability of american family
members to depart india
on a voluntary basis should they choose
to do so
my understanding is that commercial
travel continues commercial flights
continue
to take off and land in india when it
comes to
any travel restrictions as you know uh
that is something that
uh is determined in close coordination
and under uh the advice
of public health uh professionals at uh
cdc and hhs
but if those flights um were you know
under consideration to shut down it
would obviously be
up to the state department to give
americans heads up that that was a
possibility so given that you guys
haven't
issued any of those warnings should we
assume that um
no shutdown of those flights is anytime
imminent again that's not
for me to speak to i wouldn't read
anything beyond uh
read anything into the updated travel
advisory that you saw
today again my understanding is that
those commercial flights continue to
take off and land
any changes to
entry requirements or restrictions
would be dictated by um uh public health
uh
and in coordination uh with uh medical
professionals and
and uh uh um uh cbc
would give americans heads up you know
well in advance of that
the state department as a regular course
communicates uh with americans around
the world uh through our embassies
that's just for like health and disease
that's correct that's correct because
the cdc is
good at that but they don't maybe not
know so much about well in
in in in some 80 of uh countries around
the world
are at this level four precisely because
of public health concerns that's right
but you're
still doing you're still factoring your
own
metrics into you know for
violence of course of course yes
sending its team of officials to the u.s
embassy in delhi
uh as quickly as as possible uh as soon
as possible i should say
uh the the cdc team was uh
mentioned uh in the white house fact
sheet as you know i know they will be
engaging
uh as quickly uh as possible but i'd
have to refer you to the cdc for
uh specific details yes
independence journalist as you know sir
nowadays afghanistan has a sensitive
time
afghan women they are very worried
although they have a lot of achievement
this is
a few example that i brought with myself
and they are really really
under bad situation psychologically can
you
give me some details short
information that what will be their
situation in future
they are really worried about their
future and also
istanbul conference for peace process as
you know taliban postponed it
and it looked at taliban as a more
powerful now
istanbul conference will take place or
not
uh well when it comes to the istanbul
conference uh we've heard from
uh the organizers that uh uh
they would uh it's unlikely to take us
during uh the month of ramadan um but
would need to refer you to the
organizers
um for uh updates um when it comes to
that
when it comes to women and girls and
thank you
for those illustrations um as you know
secretary blinken traveled to
afghanistan
shortly after president biden within
hours of president biden's speech
um from the white house and of course
while there
we met with president ghani we met with
chairman abdullah
but importantly we also met with
representatives of civil society
uh and there were some uh half dozen or
a couple more
participants in that meeting all of uh
all but one of whom uh
were women uh women who had been at the
front lines
of the games uh that the afghan people
the hard hard one gains i should say
that the afghan people
uh have achieved over uh the past 20
years and secretary blinken
determined that it was especially
important for him to not only to go to
afghanistan
but to meet with representatives of
civil society and
with afghan women um precisely to send
the signal that
even as we withdraw militarily from
afghanistan our partnership
with the people of afghanistan
will endure we have made clear
that any country that
seeks international legitimacy that
wishes not to be
a pariah needs to respect women
and girls and that includes any future
government in afghanistan
the united states will continue to
provide support
through the department of state through
usaid
for the important programs that have
supported many of
again the hard-won gains of
afghanistan's women and girls
over the past 20 years as you know
we are continuing to have a diplomatic
presence on the ground in afghanistan
that's especially important
as an element of that uh enduring
partnership
with the people of afghanistan going
forward
yes oh sorry i didn't see who was yes
there's news today that the u.s troops
are beginning to withdraw i wonder if
you can describe
the situation at the embassy has the
drawdown there begun
uh so i would need to refer you to the
department of defense uh to
speak to the um drawdown of troops um
but
the the broad point uh is that and and
president biden laid this out in his
speech that
uh the only military presence that will
remain in afghanistan is the
very limited presence required uh to
protect our embassy uh and that's
important for
the reason i was just just just
discussing even as we
disengage militarily uh from 20 years
of military um uh involvement
in afghanistan our
presence on the ground will remain
through our
embassy uh through our civilian
representatives uh including
uh our diplomats uh the as you know
uh there was uh an announcement earlier
this week that
uh we will be relocating uh some
personnel um from kabul uh these are
personnel who can do their jobs
uh elsewhere um it is a repositioning of
personnel that will allow us
to place them
uh elsewhere and also to bring in
additional personnel
who will be able to help manage uh the
drawdown uh and the implications that
has uh for
our embassy presence uh and for um those
who
uh will be able to to help um be the
conduits the diplomatic conduits to
uh the government and the people of
afghanistan
uh going forward as as we mentioned uh
this was
a drawdown order that affects only a
relatively um
small number of uh diplomats who are
based at our embassy in kabul
yes it's 100 days into this
administration
and among ambassadorial appointments
only a handful has been
has been nominated and none from the
larger missions i guess with the
exception of the u.n
um why is the process going so slowly
and does that create a void or a vacuum
in your stated efforts to repair
the damage the diplomatic damage of the
last four years well i make a couple
points
as you know there have been 11
ambassadors
put forward nine career ambassadors two
political ambassadors those two
political ambassadors
uh being ambassador uh linda thomas
greenfield uh at our mission to the u.n
uh and chris liu uh who would hold
another position at our our mission
uh to the un um but even as
uh even for those posts uh that do not
yet have
a nominee we are incredibly fortunate to
have
uh career women and men at the
department of state
uh serving in uh uh the the function
and the capacity of charges uh we have
uh in the course of our travels already
secretary blinken
uh has had an opportunity uh to meet
with those uh
individuals um uh all of whom uh
are again career professionals who have
years if not
in most cases decades of experience
in the department of state so it's not
that there is a leadership vacuum
anywhere
uh in the world here not here at maine
state
not anywhere uh around the world uh and
those
uh uh charges will continue uh
until they uh in some cases have a
confirmed ambassador in place
uh serve uh and just continue uh until
they
uh in some cases have a confirmed
ambassador in place
uh serve uh and to say as you know uh
this is a
a process that is handled by uh the
white house by the
um uh presidential personnel uh office
it's an office
uh that not only uh oversees overseas
nominations
for ambassadors here at the department
of state but appointees and nominees
throughout the executive branch so they
clearly have a lot of work
as we said before we've the white house
uh has put forward um uh nearly a dozen
uh nominees for um ambassadorial
positions that's in addition to the
nominees that have been put forward
uh for other positions uh here at state
including
assistant secretary and under secretary
uh positions as well uh so there's been
good progress uh that we've already seen
and i expect you'll be hearing
uh more from uh president biden from the
white house uh when it comes to
personnel announcements going
of the forward people that you know
there's no dearth of leadership
experience with
that when the previous administration
had the same
made the similar argument uh
about the lack of ambassadors or lack of
people
that people many people who are involved
in this administration including i
believe yourself
were pretty dismissive of that argument
scoffed at it saying
people are being sidelined and that kind
of thing and
so i just like to make the point that
the same explanation you just gave and
the same
reasoning was uh was not well received
by
people in the current administration's
articles when it was made by the
previous
well i'd be interested perhaps in
another video and hearing
exactly what remarks you're referring to
but i think you may be referring to
[Music]
efforts to sideline individuals
rather than nominate individuals in the
first place but
maybe for another venue yes
thank you i have couple of questions but
i would start by iran
a team of the u.s officials is traveling
to the middle east
this week for talks with us allies there
can you share
any information on who from state
departments
would participate in those talks what
are the main stops
of the u.s delegation and is that part
of
paving the the ground from now for a
potential deal with iran
that would come within weeks as
predicted by the
israeli ambassador here in washington
well we don't have details to share at
this point what i can
confirm however is that a senior
interagency delegation will be traveling
over the coming week to discuss a number
of important matters
related to u.s national security in
ongoing efforts to de-escalate tensions
uh in the middle east i suppose i would
uh
hasten to add that uh this delegation is
not focused on any one issue
um uh uh certainly not focused uh just
on
uh iran and anything that may emanate
from
the ongoing discussions in vienna
when it comes to those discussions in
vienna i would use this as an
opportunity to to make the point that
we are now in the third round of what
promises to be a multi-round
exercise it continues to be
a venue that
where we've been able to engage
indirectly with the
iranian delegation in um largely
thoughtful
um business-like um constructive uh
dialogue but uh there is still a great
distance to travel and what we have said
before
about having more road ahead of us uh uh
then road behind us uh remains accurate
there are positive signs from every uh
everyone all the parties that
participate in those talks
agree that there is sort of breakthrough
so is it fair to say that a deal is
within
within reach uh it is fair to say that
some
progress has been made we have a better
understanding
of what we might need to do were iran to
go back into compliance
and uh it is our assessment that the
iranians have a better sense of what
they would need to do to resume
uh their compliance uh with the jcpoa
but that remains a hypothetical it
remains
uh an if and big challenges remain i i
think it is fair to say that we are not
on the cusp
of any breakthrough and again uh there
is a um a potentially long
road um ahead of us i think uh since you
raised it i would just
make the point that um there's been a
heavy focus
um on what the united states might need
to do
were iran to resume its compliance with
the jcpoa i think what is often omitted
from that discussion uh is
the other side of that equation uh and
that is what iran
would need to do to resume its
compliance with its commitments under
the 2015
uh nuclear deal uh
the fact is that iran's
nuclear program has been galloping ahead
uh since the previous administration
left the nuclear deal
uh in 2018. uh iran uh
as of recently had ten times uh the
amount of enriched uranium
permitted under the deal um and it has
made more uh ever since
uh uh since that assessment uh came down
it is spinning cascades of
advanced centrifuges uh that are
prohibited
by the deal its breakout time which as
you may recall was at a full year
when the deal was in effect is by most
accounts
uh now a matter of months uh
so it is fair to say that this is a
crisis that we
inherited uh this was a crisis that was
precipitated
uh by um uh uh
both sides um distancing themselves uh
from the iran deal um if
iran were to resume its compliance with
the nuclear deal it would of course
require iran
to significantly roll back its nuclear
program
and once again block every conceivable
pathway to a nuclear weapon that is
precisely what the
jcpoa did it set forth
in verifiable uh and permanent terms
uh restrictions that would permanently
uh
prevent iran from acquiring a nuclear
weapon
that's what is at stake here uh for us
that remains our ultimate objective to
see iran's pathways to a nuclear weapon
once again permanently and verifiably
blocked
i believe iran was the main topic of
discussion today
in today's meeting between secretary
blinken
and u.s officials including
the chief of mossad and the israeli
ambassador in
washington can you share any readout of
this meeting please
i don't have any such meeting to confirm
or to read out
what i will say however is that um we
have
been in close contact uh with our
israeli counterparts as you know
uh jake sullivan met in washington with
uh israeli national security adviser
mira bin shabbat
earlier this week where of course iran
was
on the agenda uh rob mali um was
a brief the group for part of that
we have as you heard from state
department officials
uh updated our israeli
counterparts uh before every round of
negotiations
after every round of negotiations and
we've been consulting with them
during um these negotiations as well so
um we have conducted ourselves with a
great deal of uh
transparency uh knowing that the united
states and israel
share a common interest here of course
and that is seen to it
again as i said before that iran is
verifiably and permanently
uh prevented from acquiring a nuclear
weapon
also welcomed what it uh called
the change of tone uh from saudi uh
arabia how would this
uh conciliatory
tone between the two sides affect the
so many uh crisis in the region
including yemen with the fourth visit of
the special envoy
tim linderking to the region well i
wouldn't want to uh characterize
uh the tone uh that's uh uh
maybe heard from iran or heard from
riyadh
for uh that matter um but since you
raised it um
uh as you heard from us last night uh
special envoy linder king
um uh is uh as of today in saudi arabia
uh he'll also
travel to oman on these on this trip
he's meeting with senior government
officials and is always working closely
with the u.n special envoy
martin griffiths as part of this his
discussions are focused on ensuring
the regular and unimpeded delivery of
commodities and humanitarian assistance
throughout yemen uh and of course
promoting that lasting uh ceasefire
uh and advancing uh that political
process that we've invested in
since the earliest days earliest hours
even
of this administration the iraqi news
agency quoted the iraqi oil minister
hassan abdul-jabbar
as saying that his country intends to
import gas from
syria without giving uh details but he
was
speaking after meeting with with his
syrian counterpart
i'm wondering if you are aware of those
reports and
if such move would violate the u.s
sanctions on uh al-assad regime
i uh we'll see if we can get you a
response there
son just for the past few hours uh
palestinian
authority president obama saying that uh
palestinian elections can go ahead uh if
there's a building in jerusalem in east
jerusalem
does us have any position on um first of
all voting in jerusalem whether that
should go ahead again
this time and whether the palestinian
election should be held at schedule
uh we do have an opinion it's and it's
our opinion as we have always said
uh that the exercise of democratic
elections is a matter
uh for the palestinian people uh and for
the palestinian leadership to determine
well no it is it is actually an
affirmative position
uh we believe in an inclusive political
process uh bush administration said when
there was an election
gossip oh well uh it continues to be
our position that uh democratic
elections are a matter
for uh the people um uh
and the palestinian leadership to
determine by the way
uh you know that happens to be our
position on elections around the world
um we never dictate
um when it comes to elections when it
comes to the outcome of elections
i'm sorry so it's okay if the election
isn't democratic
uh free and fair is when it comes to
democratic elections we think it's up to
the people i mean don't you want
shouldn't they always be democratic
jerusalem
sir if the palestinian leadership
decides it wants
to hold elections in jerusalem they
should be allowed it should happen is
what you're saying
or not it is a matter for the
palestinian leadership and the
palestinian people to decide
it is a matter for the palestinian uh
people and leadership
uh to decide on the exercise of
democratic elections
israel should not interfere it doesn't
matter for the palestinian people in
leadership
relationship with al qaeda if they don't
disconnect their relationship
what will be the u.s reaction to the
taliban
and also best of european united states
when they were in afghanistan are lost
or
i'm sorry i didn't catch the last part
of your question united states
winners they lost foreign afghanistan
did we did we win or did we lose the war
in afghanistan yes uh so
the the point uh that i think is
critically important uh to understanding
um uh this administration's position uh
what president
biden laid out is the very simple fact
that
we went into afghanistan uh together
with our our partners
uh in 2001 in october 2001
uh with one goal in mind uh and that was
uh
to uh uh degrade uh
al qaeda the al qaeda presence that was
there the al-qaeda
leadership that had directed uh the
attack
um on the united states on 9 11.
osama bin laden was killed more just
about
10 years ago that is a mission that
due to the heroics
of our military and other interagency
partners
um we were able to accomplish it is a
mission that was not only
uh accomplished successfully and that
was in our interests
but also in the interests of all of our
partners around the world
who had come under threat from al qaeda
that was
at the time based in afghanistan
so the president um made very clear
that having accomplished that military
mission it was time for
uh our service members uh to depart
um but again he was equally clear that
even as we withdraw militarily
uh we will remain engaged diplomatically
remain engaged diplomatically
uh with the afghan leadership and remain
engaged
uh diplomatically uh with the afghan
people
when it comes to the taliban um as you
know we spent
quite some time studying the uh
agreement that the previous
administration agreed to
uh the stipulation that was in the
agreement from
the previous administration uh that uh
american troops needed to be on the way
out uh as of
uh may first we've spoken of the mixed
record
when it comes to the taliban in adhering
to the agreement we've spoken to
the levels of violence in afghanistan
that remain unacceptably
high and i think the point remains that
if
uh the taliban wants any semblance
of international legitimacy uh if the
taliban
does not wish to be a international a
global pariah
uh that it must cease any ties with al
qaeda or other terrorist groups
what makes you guys so convinced that
the taliban
are fear being a pariah
i mean they were pretty much a pariah
back in the
back in the 90s and they didn't seem to
mind
do you think things have changed that
much that they now are
so eager to be a part of the
international community uh
if they will change their ways the
consequence of uh being a pariah
of lacking into any international uh
legitimacy um is uh
uh i think in our minds um
the inability to have any durability to
uh that sort of
movement if the taliban wants to be part
of afghanistan's future
they're not going to be able to do so um
if they
do not respect the rights of women and
girls if they do not
sever ties with al qaeda or other
terrorist groups
so it is uh not only consistent with our
values and with our interests
uh that the taliban do this but if the
taliban
think they have a future in uh
afghanistan uh it's also in their
interest
the taliban don't care about what your
values are they care about their values
and i and i i i why why are you guys
convinced
that their values include not being an
international pariah when
the evidence strong evidence from the
previous time they were in power
showed that they didn't care because
engaging in these sorts of practices or
failing to follow through with these
sorts of commitments
won't afford the taliban any degree of
legitimacy or
durability and i think i think
durability
uh is certainly something that the
taliban uh
seeks to achieve they would not be able
to achieve that
um absent these steps in
iceland and uh
i wouldn't want to get ahead of things i
would
make the broader point that
in the midst of these very challenging
times
in the bilateral relationship with
russia
in the context of a relationship
that we would like to be both stable
and predictable we know
that uh an ingredient to seeing that
through
uh is engagement should be engagement uh
that is why uh we hope uh
uh and we expect that not all avenues
for
engagement will be shut off um and that
is why
uh you have heard us uh object to
the steps that we've heard from moscow
to limit
our diplomatic presence uh in russia
we know that if we are to inject
some degree of stability some degree of
predictability
into this relationship there has to be
uh or there needs to be
some semblance of engagement and so
that's why president biden uh in his
conversation with president putin the
other day
held out the prospect of a meeting
between the two
presidents in the coming weeks but when
it comes to
uh the upcoming uh arctic conference i
just don't have anything to uh preview
at this time
of uh the russian uh local
staff at the missions is that still in
limbo
well um what i will say uh and and to go
back to what i was referencing a moment
ago
is that uh moscow uh formally notified
the state department
of portions of the additional actions um
it
is choosing to impose uh on our uh
mission to russia but we don't have uh
the full details
of that yet um we are in the process of
reviewing the measures that have been
formally
related to us we know that
they would have a negative impact on our
mission's ability to
operate and again consequently on our
ability to engage uh diplomatically
with our russian counterparts and we of
course uh do reserve the the right to
respond what we have always said
is that uh the measures that the white
house that president biden
announced uh the other week those were
not escalatory those were
a response uh to the
uh attack on our democracy uh that we
had seen from uh the russians it was a
response to solar winds
um uh
and so that's how we look at it um it is
not that we have escalated
and we continue to review
the what the russians have uh
communicated
uh to us knowing that we do reserve uh
the right to respond
uh depending on what we hear and what we
assess uh going forward but also knowing
that again
uh we need to keep uh those lines of
communication open
uh if we are to inject some degree of
stability and predictability into the
relationship
the secretary yesterday mentioned that
he's raised the issue of rferl can you
be any more specific about
what the u.s wants to see there and how
you hope to resolve that
well uh media freedom uh as we know uh
is has come increasingly under threat
from moscow the russian government's
long-running campaign uh against
independent media
and voices has only intensified
in recent months we've seen of course a
broad crackdown
on human rights and those seeking to
achieve
a greater degree of inclusiveness and
participation
in russian society only to see
the russians attempt to quash that
for more than 70 years now rferl
has been a vital source of objective
news and information for the people of
russia
and an important link between our two
countries uh
as secretary blinken said he has raised
uh
this issue with uh foreign minister
lavrov
uh he and other officials have called on
the russian government to reconsider its
actions against rferl
and we have heard we've been gratified
to hear
statements from some of our
international partners
joining that call unfortunately the
russian government
is increasingly intolerant of outside
perspectives
we've made clear that russia's actions
against rferl
and other media organizations labeled as
so-called foreign agents reflect
significant
intolerance and oppressive restrictions
will continue to raise
this case the case of rferl freedom of
expression
within russia more broadly and human
rights
more broadly as well with our russian
counterparts
should the russian government continue
to move to forcibly shut down
rferl uh we will respond
um this week's
of policy currently in haiti one of the
more serious things he is saying that
the us shouldn't support the uh
the constitutional referendum um that's
coming up i know that generally you
don't want to
respond to everything from the hill but
in this case does the united states
still support the
or does the united states support the
constitutional referendum in haiti
well you're right we we don't comment on
uh correspondence uh from the hill but
um let me just give you a sense of
of our view of this um and that is that
holding overdue elections
uh are the democratic means to end
haiti's irregular and prolonged rule by
decree
and to restore uh the legislature's role
in haitian democracy presidential
elections scheduled for the fall
of this year are necessary to transfer
power peacefully and on a timely basis
from one democratically elected leader
to another
uh we have repeatedly stated that
constitutional reform
uh is for the haitian people to decide
uh we've emphasized uh and this goes
back to part of your question that the
us government
um that we've emphasized to the
government of haiti that the
u.s government will not provide
financial support for a constitutional
referendum will not for a constitutional
effort right do you oppose it being held
or is it just a matter of u.s
uh it is again uh when it comes to
uh those moves these are for the haitian
people to decide but when it comes to
uh that referendum it is not something
uh that we will provide
financial support for why is it
necessary
for presidential elections to transfer
power peacefully and
and not for the palestinians uh as we
said
this this is for you
you said that that's up to the
palestinian people well in haiti
you say that these are necessary
why aren't elections for the
palestinians
we're talking about the timing uh of the
palestinian
elections that is for uh
this is this is written into um
uh this would be consistent um with what
is called for
in heating uh yeah i i i i i 15 years i
i don't think you can compare
uh two countries uh uh in some cases
we're going to have
uh apples and oranges he made a blanket
statement that elections are up
but there are also key differences
between the context uh in haiti
uh and with palestinian authority i saw
one final question yes yes
what would the u.s government do in
order to revive
the political process
in order to counter the fact that
president assad may be
in the power for another seven years and
would the u.s consider
nominating special envoy to lead those
efforts
uh well i um don't have any uh personnel
announcements to preview um at this time
what i would say is that um
per u.n security council resolution two
two five four
uh steps should be taken towards con
convening a free and fair
elections very importantly uh pursuant
to a new constitution
administered under the supervision of
the un in which all
syrians including internally to place
syrians displaced syrians refugees
and the diaspora might be able to
participate
we believe that stability in syria and
the greater region
is best served through a political
process that produces peaceful
outcomes in syria we are committed to
working with allies partners
uh in the u.n to ensure that a durable
uh political solution remains within
reach even as we do that
uh we are also doing everything we can
and you heard uh from
secretary blinken uh himself to provide
humanitarian relief
uh to the people of syria who have uh
suffered so immensely
under uh the brutal repression uh
the brutality of bashar al-assad
we've spoken to our commitments to the
tune of hundreds of millions of dollars
not only providing that aid but
also seeking to provide humanitarian
access to ensure that that aid
can reach those most vulnerable and
those
in need we have done that in the face of
resistance
including within the un security council
we continue
to work on this issue just knowing how
vitally important it is
to the well-being of the syrian people
thank you very much everyone
you